welcome back to Las Vegas now as we look
back on 2022 A lot happened in the world
of real estate and Las Vegas real estate
now the sponsors of this segment are
helping us break it all down so joining
us today we have Harvey blingfield
Harvey so great to see you great to be
back thanks for having me thanks for
being here a lot to talk about 2022 was
a big year how would you describe it
overall it was a crazy year because of
the the chef the ship turned
dramatically from a strong seller's
market to a more neutral Market buyer's
market I brought a chart a little line
graph with me I don't know if we can
look at that and I can show you guys
that uh basically what happened the
yellow line represents our inventory
which you can see at the beginning was
very low and got high but big many
people don't know recently it's actually
dropped a little bit the blue line is
the median price which stayed between
430 and 480 it's right it's actually
lower than it was a year ago okay and
the Orange Line represents the activity
we've had every month now you can see
it's been dropping off the last month
was one of the least amount of activity
we've had in a long time in terms of
single-family homes here in the valley
wow yeah lots of ups and downs to look
at on that graph here and are we going
to see something similar as we head into
the new year what are your predictions
well the predictions uh come from
variety of sources but mortgage rates
have a big impact on what's going to
happen in real estate obviously and
interest rates in the economy in general
there's lots of people out there who are
predicting that mortgage rates have seen
their Peak and we probably see them come
off of their numbers a little bit I
think that's important to note and as
the year progresses the economy improves
I believe housing will also jump back a
little bit but the thing is I'm hearing
a lot now is buyers are being told it's
a horrible time to buy
and for some buyers that's true it may
not be the best time to buy but
everyone's different and unique and so I
want buyers out there to not ignore the
fact that right now they do have
opportunities and your interest rate may
be higher now but you can always change
it later that's really important to note
own the home and then you can always
change that rate a little bit later
maybe the rates are going to come down
everyone's predicting they will yeah I
think everyone goes through that phase
of should I buy should I sell when the
Market's hot should you just sell to
sell it's kind of this back and forth of
what to do yeah how many times have
people said Gee I wish I would have I
wish I would have I wish I would have
you know think about that and if you're
somebody who doesn't own right now
really you gotta buy I mean because if
you're renting that's a hundred percent
interest that's I mean so you can't
complain about interest rates too much
if you're renting think about buying if
you want to talk to me I won't convince
you to buy right now but I will help you
develop a plan to maybe buy some time
next year yeah and do you think that's
really helpful to just start asking
those questions and getting all those
answers before you dive into anything
clearly and if you have a good trusted
realtor by all means use that as a
resource if you don't call me I'm happy
to help your listeners happy to well
Harvey thank you so much for being here
you always have so much helpful
information for us and we appreciate it
and you're our crystal ball hey Merry
Christmas everybody happy Hanukkah and
best happy Festivus to the rest of you
thank you same to you Harvey and thank
you again to Las Vegas real estate now
for sponsoring the segment you can call
702-203-1165 or visit
lvrealestateradio.com for more Las Vegas
now we'll be right back